I got my brother Steve here and now
we're going to give you the breakdown
hoist Gracie and the Frank Shamrock he
wants three I was there for the first
two yeah I was hoist is conditioning
coach for this first you have stays
welcome to the Deshawn MIDI your host we
got another exciting episode for you as
always subscribe if you haven't already
my next guest has been chosen by Men's
Journal is one of the top hundred
trainers in the US he's been trained in
over half a century that's more than
plenty of you have been living he was a
former strength and conditioning coach
for hoist Gracie started training Gracie
Brazilian jiu-jitsu before the UFC
that's why I've got my rash guard on and
I'm ready to go ahead and throw my gear
on and benefit from his experience and
his from his knowledge that's why you
want to sit tight and go ahead and soak
in some of the great things that she's
got to share with us here on the D show
with Steve Maxwell don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
[Music]
this is the black so my friend how are
you excellent great to be here and the
sunny Chicago thank you for being with
us they are on the Dean show so again I
said that's that's uh that's more than
people probably have been living half a
century so I started as a ten year old
boy that my father's basement and a
little town called Carlisle Pennsylvania
and I forgot to mention that you were
one of the first Gracie jiu-jitsu
certified by the Gracie's to have your
Academy in the u.s. well when when we
first started out of course Brazilian
jiu-jitsu was completely unknown there's
like eighty nine ninety you would say
Brazilian jiu-jitsu people would say
whoa she's just as Japanese then no not
Brazilians you say yep but it's Japanese
they just couldn't wrap their mind
around the idea of Brazilian jiu-jitsu
and it was totally unheard of until
after the UFC of course but after the
UFC hit of course there was an explosion
of everyone you know wanting to jump on
the gravy train
yeah like flies buzzing around the cake
as they say yeah and there was a lot of
guys with basically fake credentials and
a lot of people jumping in teaching they
had no business teaching at all there no
teaching experience or background so
master Elio Gracie and his oldest son
Horton wanted to have some type of
instructor training program where they
would teach you how to teach I was the
first person to graduate from that
program
now I mentioned who's Gracie before I
ask you more questions about that you
saw this horse great yeah yeah one two
but this is a three surprise a lot of us
what was your breakdown on that would
you think of the fight this last one
this last one yeah this was number three
yeah no I mean first of all it just
shows you the power of his jiu-jitsu you
know even though shamrock I'm sure have
studies and so forth voice was born in
the mat and there was some a little
controversy you know ken complaining
about the shot to the groin but in the
original fights everything was going you
could do groin shots elbows to the back
of the head stomping your governor's
down up kicks all the things that are
illegal now and of course there was no
gloves which changes the game a lot you
know
ground-and-pound it didn't really exist
back then because you know you're gonna
break your hand on someone's elbow or
the top of their head so you know boys
always improved you know what an amazing
fighter he is even now yeah you know
he's not a young guy anymore there was
some controversy towards the end what
did you do I was the closest to because
when he first started when they did the
u.s. there was not there was no rules
there was nothing except respectful
respectfully no eye gouging or groin
shot but even everything was permitted
everything was permitted so I mean to me
it was a fair fight
yeah it you know it wasn't as if hoist
went out trying to get a nice shot and
it just happened in the course of the
fight yeah that's what happens yeah you
know so I like I was thrilled to see
said I think I was also it was amazing
I've heard you say so many times even
with all your experience your humble
knowing that you're still a student and
I'm still a student I got my rash guard
as you see yeah voice yeah it's not just
Warner for nothing maybe you've created
in your style yeah so work work by day
train by night and I come in and I was
like taught so much that with all your
years of training so much wisdom that we
can benefit from your experiences and we
want the audience also tell us being
with the Gracie's this was before like
many of us we saw the in action or the
UFC and people were fascinated people
with 10 different black belts whatever
striking arts and
then they saw that wow this is you know
amazing that this family is able to you
know this guy 170 pounds you know and
smalls thin he's taking him down
destroying people got into the Jitsu
from this but you were actually this is
before the UFC this is before did you
get to see tell us some story did you
get to see some Gracie in action live
with these challenges that oh yeah
certainly did it was really interesting
because the first seminar I had was like
89 and I went under protest a friend of
mine was telling me about the Gracie's
and the Jiu Jitsu style being a former
NCAA Division one wrestler you know I I
was pretty egotistical you know I
figured out what are these guys going to
show me and that first seminar Euler
just tapped me like a typewriter and I
couldn't believe that there's a little
tiny guy you know there's a little
skinny guy could just basically kick my
butt and I was utterly shocked
that's that wow I gotta learn this you
know so many guys that will happen to
them and then if you would never see him
again and I never understood that
because even today if someone had a
martial art and you know he could he
could show me how superior would I would
want to learn that art and so I made it
my mission I wanted to learn Gracie Jiu
Jitsu
I just opened up my own gym at that time
mmm exercise it was the first Gracie
training Association on the eastern
seaboard before hands our Gracie before
and Indies we're going back to the time
of even Craig Kukoc maybe you've heard
that name like one of the early early
guys so at that time the Gracie's had a
challenge poori on had written a article
in Playboy magazine and in which he
challenged anyone to come and take their
martial art against gracie jiu-jitsu you
he would put a hundred thousand dollars
in there you know so it was true it's
not a myth four hundred thousand
$100,000 and the person was supposed to
come in and put their hundred thousand
and you know one big pile and then
winner would take all but what was
happening where people were coming and
challenging without the money and of
course the you know the greatest one
would have large so they were getting
challenge matches that
the Gracie Academy and you can see a lot
of those in the old greasy and action
tapes that was the first video that I
had seen Torian had made this one of the
original in action tapes and I was just
blown away with with what I saw and when
I opened up my school in Philly I would
get guys coming in to want to challenge
Oz yeah and I would say wait a second
we're just bluebells you know purple
bout and you know you want to call hoist
or or in or Hickson and they would still
insist and it developed great confidence
because it was quite frightening some of
these guys are pretty formidable looking
guys but without the knowledge of
jiu-jitsu to back them up actually the
fights were pretty easy pretty easy and
we weren't even that skilled at the time
yeah and it just proved to me how
amazingly effective this martial art is
you know mano-a-mano very hard to beat
as you juice a guy if you don't know
what to do in the ground this and the
fight will go to the ground that's why
we followed out it's been proven the
most effective martial art in the world
not just by theory but by action by
action there's no yeah I mean it's not
like you know one of these things like
the dim mocked death touch of something
that is just too dangerous ever to do I
mean you know that this stuff actually
works so yeah we get guys boxers kick
boxers Taekwondo tagging tank pseudo you
know the tough guys were always the
wrestlers that was gonna be a long
struggle I remember I had this guy he
was a former n-c-double-a division 3 guy
he weighed about 210 pounds I was at the
time I was already in my 40s and maybe
138 pounds soaking wet
I went almost 45 minutes with this guy
before I finally sunk arm triangle from
the guard yeah and I felt like I was in
a blender he's just throwing me all over
the place but he couldn't really hurt me
he couldn't really finish me couldn't
really do anything and but it built a
lot of confidence a lot of confidence
amazing we're gonna go ahead and take a
break and we'll be right back with more
with Steve Maxwell on the D show don't
go anywhere
what are we doing here and where are we
gonna go it's like we just woke up one
morning and then it's welcome to the
show don't ask any questions just go
with the flow make as much money as you
can you try your best not to get broke
copy everything you see on the TV from
the hairstyles to the clothes and don't
think too often just do exactly as
you're told and if you ever get confused
and just turn towards the alcohol you
still hear thoughts then just turn up
the radio as you learn to live a
lifestyle of drugs sex and rock and roll
but in all honesty I just need to know
is there more to the cycle than growing
and getting old living and dying just to
leave behind a happy home and a whole
lot of property that somebody else is
going to own I just really need to know
before the caskets closed because I'm
not willing to gamble with my soul nor
am I ready to take any chances these are
just simple life questions and I'm just
searching for some answers like what are
we doing here and what is our purpose
how did we get here and who made us so
perfect and what happens once we go or
is this world or really worth it
subscribe right now back here on the D
show with Steve Maxwell now Steve you
also had a chance I mean we got to talk
a little bit about the the history and
how you started and you also got to
spend some time on the farm with Helio
Gracie I did it was one of the frigates
of milk it was an amazing amazing time
Elia Gracie was a very generous host I
had visited him around 1992 I believe it
was I went down trained with oiler at
the you might to school and then I
returned later when hoist was preparing
for a fight and stayed there about a
month and got a chance to see
up close the Gracie diet and of course
you know Ella Gracie was very strict
about the way he ate he was very hale
and hearty right up until the very end
very even when he was in his late 80s
and 90s he was still very spry and
moving around and he knew that I liked
milk raw milk and he would go out he had
his own dairy farm his own chickens
he had a lake where it was stocked with
fish you know he'd go out and catch a
fish for dinner I mean it's pretty
amazing
si II grew on the trees right outside
the house you know all the tropical
fruits everything everything it was like
like a garden being in there really and
he would go out and milk the cow and
bring me a big frothy picture of ya of
nice raw milk it was delicious
real milk yeah real raw yeah straight
from the cow many people don't know that
the number one allergenic food according
to the FDA is milk but it's not real no
we're talking about homogenized
pasteurized fake food as we call it once
they homogenized it you know they
destroy all the natural enzymes and and
so forth when you get it raw it's a
whole different food from the stuff that
you find in the store even even raw milk
though if it's sitting around too long
it is an ideal I mean the ideal would be
to get it you know right from the cow as
you were getting it yeah yeah you know a
couple days it's okay quickly because
there's no preservatives or anything you
know it quickly begins to break down and
there are a lot of American Health
pioneers in the early days Harvey
Kellogg and Bernard McFadden and some of
these guys who were very much into the
milk cure were people that were
suffering different ailments instead of
outright fasting they would drink raw
milk only the only food they would take
like a mono diet for 30 days and there's
like testimonial after testimonial as to
the effectiveness of the milk cure gave
the digestion a chance to to to relax
and not be so overburdened and gave the
body a chance to detoxify while still
giving you some some good nutrients and
calories so that you weren't so tired
I've taken water fast
also as a cure but you need to lay down
and rest a lot when you're taking a
water fast yeah you don't have any
energy plus your body's busy detoxify as
far as these arcs of vacation I believe
water faster superior but they do make
you do get quite tired but mono diet
like the milk here is a way that if you
have to work and you have duties that
you just can cannot attend to then
something like that is a really good
alternative yeah we we actually fast we
fast it's usually from from Sun before
sunrise to sunset no food no drink
nothing and then there's a new thing now
with the intermittent fasting yeah it's
what I've done yeah I kind of do it
major benefits they're discovering for
me I'd like to push my lunch bag every
day to like 11 or 12 I usually arise
around between five and six yeah and I
think there's a lot of benefit your body
is busy getting rid of metabolic wastes
there the day before in the early
morning and having a big heavy breakfast
is definitely a burden on your system
yes better just to have nothing or eat
very lightly and this is very important
you should not be eating before you have
a bowel movement in the morning I know
it sounds kind of kind of gross but it's
really really important that you
eliminate before you start filling your
body with what about water waters fines
okay you can start starting is recommend
starting with water yeah water in the
morning how some people put a lemon or
what's the apple cider vinegar yeah no
that's fine you know I just drink water
myself water personally it's a little
bit and then eat yeah if you like a
little coffee it's okay you know a
little coffee is not a terrible thing
I've been into matcha tea lately it's it
has a lot of chlorophyll in it yeah and
a lot of really good antioxidants and
there is a mouth stimulating effect to
it there is a little caffeine in there
yeah so I usually drink matcha tea
sometimes mixed with a little coconut
water yeah you know feta fed up have you
seen forget about it
they're lost 600,000 food items in
America 80% of them have added sugar
your brain lights up with sugar just
like it does with cocaine or heroin
you're gonna become an addict you end up
with one of the great public health
epidemics of our time this is the first
generation of American children expected
to lead shorter lives than their parents
this is like a catalyst that really
opened my eyes you know to one of the to
the dangers and the importance of eating
real food and staying away from you know
one example of white procces refined
sugars one out of every three Americans
will have diabetes those diseases are
being driven by sugar this is the
fundamental problem nobody's talking
about in society seems like this is
something with the marketing campaign
from the food industry that's why you
mentioned earlier the statistic almost
70 percent of people now here are obese
and it's pretty bad and the rest of the
world is quickly catch yeah talk to us
about have you seen the movie I strike I
did everyone watch fed up like wow yeah
and it's really sad and right now in the
United States we are basically the
fattest nation on earth but China is
quickly catching up the UK not too far
behind Germany you know all the
industrialized countries in the world
they're very quickly taking on the fast
food addiction that the American public
have and it's really undermining the
health the world over I extensively as
you know I'm a digital nomad yeah I
don't live in any one spot I'm always
moving to different country and even in
the Middle East I'm seeing a lot of
overweight people that are not eating
well monkey see monkey do because we're
following this culture you know the
norms here and then that stuff is just
past McDonald's is if we're trading it's
infiltrating every one of the saddest
things ever saw I went to what was
probably one of the greatest paradises
ever on earth was Tahiti
and there was two McDonald's on the
island of Tahiti and the drive-through
would literally be backed up for miles
the Tahitians were so obese it was so
sad because what a magnificent people
you know yeah we're gonna take a break
I'm excited we got a lot more questions
to ask you to benefit us and the viewers
we'll be right back with more hannity
show don't go anywhere
I want you to imagine you wake up and in
front of you are a bunch of guys running
around kicking a ball no goals no lines
no rules what would you think but is
that your life surely every sport has
its goal every game has its end it has
its objective it has its rules how about
life how about our life isn't there a
goal to life isn't there a purpose an
objective that we have to reach we think
so
the Koran tells us that we exist in
order to worship God and worshiping God
means knowing God as the Quran says when
the holocrons in the will insert allure
Leah badoon worship though is not some
narrow small thing its wide its vast it
encompasses everything that the human
being does everything that you do
everything that you think everything
that you feel can be done thought said
felt in a way that is either pleasing or
displeasing to God the purpose of life
is to try and do everything in a way
that God loves and God is pleased with
that is your goal subscribe right now
back here on the D show with Steve
Maxwell where Tom out fed up have you
seen have you heard of Ty Bollinger
doctor is brainwashed when he gets out
of medical school because the Medical
School has too much subsidization of the
professors who are being paid by the
drug company so the professor never
teaches any student in medical school
why don't you try vitamin C they're
going to tell him the latest drug that's
why designed specifically you know there
are about over a century ago
there's foundations that Carnegie and
Rockefeller Foundation's who sort of
engineered the curriculum through their
grants and donations are you wondering
what dr. McCulloh meant when he
mentioned that the Carnegie's and the
Rockefeller Foundation's engineered
medical school curriculum over a century
ago he was referring to the flexin
report of 1910 which we covered in our
last documentary this is a man whose
mother and father died to cancer and
then his five other family members is
called the truth about cancer a global
quest all across the United States
interviewing doctors scientists
researchers and cancer patients to learn
what they were doing to treat cancer
have you heard of this I have not but
wrongly recommended I do know the cancer
industry is 50% of people living today
will have cancer would you know that
almost 50% of the people alive today
will face cancer did you know that one
in four males alive today will die from
cancer one out of four will go ahead
will die from it and many of this as
they uncovered that go back to the food
short 95 percent of chronic diseases are
are because the food choices were making
but there's no there's no there's no
accident people are getting cancer I
mean it's not just like something that
this happens to you know you have to
work to get it it's not like some
mysterious thing that just hits you you
know people with these with these type
of diets and of course the smoking and
so forth but there's some uncontrollable
factors too you know like the
environmental pollution you know you
heard about the Flint water crisis and
so forth you okay there are something
some things out of your control but a
lot of stuff is in your control there
was a turn of America there was a turn
of the century
American physician by the name of dr.
John children he uses a kind of a
variation of the greasy diet which I
follow very religiously and it's
basically food combining diet very
similar to the gracie diet or Sheldon's
food combining diet and children even
back then was noticing that a lot of
these so-called cancers aren't real
cancer they're like a pre cancer and
they can still be nipped in the bud by
changing your diet primarily through
fasting and he he cured many people
according to totin once you get true
cancer it's pretty much a done deal
but there's oh there's a lot of time
between where this pre cancer type
condition occurs and before you you get
the full-blown cancer I'm really on the
the philosophy the way that you know
this ty Bollinger he goes out and he
interviews I'm not talking about you
know he first talks about the facts that
most doctors I didn't know this they
know nothing about you know the basics
of nutrition but if you look at the
amount of training that I receive it was
probably about two or three hours in
medical school once I got out into
training my internship my residency
which was a five-year long I don't think
I got any training at all and from then
on to now there's probably zero amount
of training and nutrition the poor
things don't study nutrition at medical
school and for the bulk of them post
qualification training consists of
courses that are dished out to them by
the pharmaceutical industry I'm pretty
skeptical about the quality of the
training that they receive having said
all that I went to med school myself
they gave us a whole hour on
Nutritionals a whole hour in four years
of medical school mm-hmm and they told
us they're spite of an A and B 1 and B 2
and C and D and they're in alphabetical
order and you can look them up and then
they told us some really basic facts we
got a whole hour first of all how much
training did you receive on nutrition
when you were in medical school because
I know here in the states it's almost
none yeah I know much not much no stool
yeah yeah close to none very little
in medical school they don't teach you
they don't teach you anything about
nutrition you know about the power of
food you know you heard of Hippocrates
who said let food be your medicine
medicine be your food but then you have
the bet the good who who got better and
they actually wouldn't be out and beyond
and they talk about you know just giving
the body what it needs to heal itself
because we're always in a state of
healing and he goes on and talks to
people all over the world who have
helped to cure cancer through natural
means through proper dieting through
without the chemo which is 160 billion
dollar industry okay right now if I got
if I was diagnosed with cancer I would
not do chemo I would fast they talk
about fasting fasting is probably one of
the most powerful cure children talks a
lot about that in his book talk see me
explain and this was almost written 100
years ago this guy I already saw the
writing on the wall
he was railing against you know big
pharma surgical companies and you know
drugs and so forth but with all this
stuff too you can't you can't eliminate
the mental emotional spiritual aspect
yes yes because a lot of these diseases
are created by impure thoughts
created by negative thinking negative
emotional patterns anger hate jealousy
greed if you don't eliminate this from
your life thoughts are things and they
create these negative conditions in our
body so people are overlooking that
whole spiritual aspect of the whole
thing it's so important to control your
thoughts and not allow yourself to be
immersed in this type of negative
thinking this is a whole nother avenue
that people in neglect the people
neglect no one's talking about this
aspect tell us now this is what I got I
got turned out to you by my strength and
conditioning coach I believe he was
mentioning you and I had tuned in and
you know right to the point of an
interview I believe it was you who said
that you hadn't been to a doctor in 20
years
35 35 years so I said I said hold on
he's on to something
I need to talk to this man because who
wants to be going to the doctor you know
ever every year
few times a year and then you know what
you get on drugs and then that causes
another side effect something's growing
out of your back out of your head
right so what's going on 35 years you
haven't been to the doctor if I start to
feel cold or flu symptoms
I immediately will stop eating if I
absolutely must be you know doing stuff
I'll just go maybe on a basic fruit diet
something really easy to digest and give
my body a chance to eliminate any
toxemia that's built up a lot of times
it's the combination of toxemia and
innervation just being overly tired and
if I can't I'll just take a day or two
of rest and just go either all water or
light fruits bingo you know within a
dare toads it completely turns around to
your energy back I feel better
a lot of this stuff is caused from
overeating overburdening the digestion
and so forth and I do a lot of prayer
and meditation because that's very
important as we were saying you cannot
neglect the spiritual aspect of disease
it's almost like a metaphor for things
that are going wrong in your life and
you have to take a hard look at this
it's it's it's almost as if your
thoughts can literally precipitate have
you ever had a bout of anger you know I
can remember in the past getting
extremely angry about something you know
maybe before I was aware of this and
literally coming down with like a cold
the next day stress is a killer stress
and you know think you know these type
of it negative emotions are huge
stresses and they literally affect your
endocrine system you know affect every
aspect of your body and so there's an
old Autobot it's very important to
purify and be pure in your thoughts Wow
that also reminds me of my great man I
met they had him on the program he was
sick and tired of being sick and tired
he went to the conventional doctor just
gave him more pills that didn't help and
it wasn't until he started to do some of
these things you mentioned he cleaned up
his his diet he started eating right
he strengthen the immune system cleaning
up his thoughts and he's better he
hasn't also been to the doctor in
20-some years not as long as you so
that's a science by itself you have
people here who are taking care of the
gift that the Creator is given on this
body putting it in what it needs to
function optimal performance while you
have some others now what if the some
people say look my doctor said you know
eat whatever you want this is common
amongst many many doctors who say it
doesn't matter which we just go ahead
and eat it what you want well I heard
this look at look at the health of the
average doctor yeah yeah much these guys
are not particularly healthy
I'm not going to entrust my health to a
guy like that and as you said before in
medical school you know they really
don't have one our nutrition they gave
us a whole hour on nutritionals a whole
hour in four years of medical school I
mean I didn't know that's mind-blowing
they don't have a clue it's all about
drugs Yeah right if you come in and say
doctor I'm suffering pains in my joint
and he'll say well your inflamed do you
have inflammation let's take this pill
or this drug to suppress the
inflammation but he doesn't look into
what is the cause behind the
inflammation why did we go to the source
and get rid of what's causing the
inflammation rather than just taking a
harmful drug that's going to mess up
your kidney and your liver and just try
to suppress it inflammation is the GNAT
body's natural healing response
suppressing it it makes no sense it's
like a fever you know the dog the
average doctor will suppress the fever
but the fever is your body's natural
healing response you know I mean
obviously if it gets too high you know
it's gonna be harmful but there's you
know you can put cold compresses and
things to bring the fever down yeah
without going to the harmful drug yeah
but the pharmaceutical injury you know
it's billions of billions of dollars in
the past ten years the 11 largest drug
companies made seven hundred and eleven
billion dollars the pharmaceutical
industry isn't in the business of health
and healing
it's in the business of disease
management and symptoms maintenance
whatever your symptom is we've got a co
floor and they have they have control of
modern medicine yeah where modern
medicine has made greatest steps is of
course emergency medicine you know yeah
I mean if you get busted bust your arm I
guess
shut up or something yeah just Matt you
know you tap a little bit too slow
they're pretty good with you know
putting you back together you know you
car accident Battlefield medicine and so
forth but chronic disease when it comes
to like prevention yeah and degenerative
style disease
they've gone backwards of anything in
2013 Pharma spent upwards of four
hundred and twenty-two thousand dollars
her congressman making sure the US
government knew exactly what Pharma
wanted that's a lot of influence
pharmaceutical companies are all drug
dealers
every 19 minutes someone dies of an
accidental overdose it's the worst
epidemic we face in America today I
think they knew more a hundred years ago
well all you have to do is read this guy
dr. John children it's a free pdf by the
yeah you can just go to the soil and
health library and there's like a whole
litany of natural healing books and so
forth it's there it's free to the public
and you can read yourself and educate
yourself on the way to heal yourself
without modern medicine which I think
does more harm than good this is amazing
a lot more to talk about here with Steve
Maxwell don't go anywhere we right back
that's it for this week's show guys
Steve Maxwell he shares some really good
mobility drills with me I'm excited to
continue talking with him learning from
him and I hope you guys can join me next
week as I continue on with the interview
with Steve Maxwell on the diesel